what's up y'all i'm back with the lovely
katie stevens give it up
you may wonder what we're doing with
what looks like a tropical bar for
dollhouse because it might be weird
well here to explain is our next guest
you've seen him in judas and the black
messiah bad trip
and bird box he's now the host of a new
game show called small fortune
you can see it mondays on nbc take a
look let's play small fortune
take time
oh you need to land one more
oh i got stuck in my finger no it's all
right
let's go
[Applause]
all right everybody please welcome me oh
it's the life of
[Applause]
um i loved your entrance say hi to katie
hey katie how you doing
um you got lots and everything i was a
cool entrance i'm into it i kind of want
to do it again i know i'm just saying i
feel like it was nice the music was nice
well you have a new game show um so can
you explain what small fortune is
uh small fortune is this amazingly as
you can see this model right here but
it's a bunch of games
and these small i don't know small
worlds that we created on our own we had
like 27 games
uh we got great contestants from all
over the country
a lot of them are friends and co-workers
and family
it's a lot of personality with the show
it's so much fun
i got a chance to wear a new suit every
episode almost all right all right i was
happy about that
but no this is a really fun fun game i
can't wait for you to play it
okay well okay we have we have um a game
from small fortune here so how does this
particular one work
this one is called a little tipsy that's
right
perfect yeah so so what you're going to
do is basically you're going to grab
this tray with one hand
and put the tray on one of your fingers
okay and you're gonna grab each drink
and put it on the tray
and then once you do that you're gonna
attempt
to put the tray on the table with the
drinks on the tray
why did you say attempt why are you
already why are you speaking our failure
no because i've seen people play the
game it's not
as easy as it looks so you just i know
it looks easy but it's really not and
it's like one of 27 games we had
okay i'm just saying i was a waitress so
feeling confident yeah but these are
really tight
you were a waitress too you know i smell
your competition
all right all right the competitive
nature yeah like high intensity
yeah do you feel it do you feel it all
right let's do this first
um okay well before if i go if katie
wins
her tiny tiny photo that you see in
there gets mounted on the blake shelton
wall of champions which is
horrible it's a horrible wall um but a
little rel
so you take it away you lead and you
you're asking who wants to go first yeah
who's first
i want to go first can i go first it's
your show okay i'm
going first okay so you take this
yep the tiny little okay okay okay now
you
one drink it's just a little it's a
little tilted
oh she's got it okay you can't base that
off one drink
it's just there's one on there so far
i am so impressed right now
she's making this look easy okay wow and
then
it goes a little something like this
oh wow what
i am so crazy talented
cause you said that everybody does that
i don't know i don't know if i like how
easy you're making it look because it's
not it's not
it's just my skills little bro your turn
katie
all right katie um no pressure
but i'm i'm shaking okay
all right you got this okay your turn
all right no pressure am i allowed to
maneuver or do i have to like do it from
here my limbs aren't that long
okay okay there you go
okay hopefully you didn't get too close
oh because i'm seeing how close you're
getting i'm i'm already shaking
i'm so nervous all right
i have a feeling i'm not dispersing this
weight evenly
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
can't wait to see what my concentration
face looks like
[Music]
what's the tiebreaker yes we just both
win
so my picture still goes up okay but i'm
gonna pick somebody because i mean
for gameplay that was great that's gonna
be great tv the way you just played it
oh did i do it wrong
no she just did it way better like
i twisted my body around to give those
people their dreams
that was amazing great job okay that was
a great job
so technically i won but here's the
thing
is she disagrees and here's the thing i
just really want to see
this little tiny photo on the blake
shelton wall of shoes
so it's going up there people i'm saying
we todd so thank you guys
this is awesome you can see small
fortune mondays on nbc you can also see
this on the blake shelton
wallace champions yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help